hello or glad to be here welcome to this
talk on using high performance data
processing in python specifically we're
going to be applying that to doing some
algorithmic trading just a little bit
about myself beforehand I'm a software
engineer I work for a new york-based
algorithmic trading firm so what we do
is we build mathematical models to
predict the prices of the prices of
stocks and then try and build automated
trading algorithms on top of that what I
do is I build our scalable data
processing infrastructure so we use
hundreds of data sets to try and predict
stock prices and we need easy and fast
ways to ingest all these different data
sets and different shapes and sizes and
I'm also responsible for building the
real-time trading systems that actually
execute our trades on the market when
our models have decided what to trade so
I'm primarily a Python as C++ developer
I'm trying to remove that C++ part and
replace it with rust because C++ is a
pain in the ass to use but anyway about
this talk so as we all know Haven is a
hugely popular tool for data analysis
that's the whole point of this
conference for example JetBrains survey
last year showed that data analysis is
now as popular as web development in
python so half of all use cases in
Python are now data size which is a very
different landscape to what it was say
eight or ten years ago and why is this
the case so as many of you know it's
because it suitable for research its
high-level and easy to use
doesn't require advanced programming
knowledge and enables researchers to
write very complex things very quickly
in each rate and ideas very quickly but
unlike a lot of its competitors like
MATLAB for example it's also a
general-purpose language that's useful
outside of data science this means that
it's you can just take your code from
research and easily with very little
effort slot it into a production system
rather than have to re-implement
everything from MATLAB in Python for
example so that's the Python strength is
that it's suitable for both use cases
you can iterate on ideas quickly a
research but you can also take those
ideas and deploy them in real life
systems with very little if any extra
effort so the issue is Python is slow or
at least pure Python Python is not meant
to be a fast language it's meant to be
an easy high-level easy to use language
any benchmark that you that you actually
do against faster languages like C or
C++ Python will always lose out which
means actually is
bad for research PR - because it means
that you're iterating very slowly
because all the calculations you're
doing a taking up hundreds of times
longer and it's actually bad for
production because you can't run time
sensitive data processing tasks without
actually having to go with a faster
language so the solution is to use
pythons data processing ecosystem what
we're gonna focus on here is numpy I
know many of you have already used numpy
but many of you might not know how it
actually works internally and why it's
so fast which is the purpose of this
talk and as many of you know part number
is the heart of scientific computing in
python stores and operates on C
structures to avoid the slowness that
Python has and it's the foundation of a
lot of packages like numpy pandas and so
on which I'll show you or use on a daily
basis so our focus is to show how to's
numpy to process numerical data explore
how numpy uses vectorization to
dramatically boost performance or
keeping the productivity that python
gives us we're gonna be building an
algorithmic trading strategy using stock
pricing data we're gonna be processing
that stock pricing data in pure Python
speeding it up using the unplanned
vectorization and then speeding up even
more using another tool called number
the final optimized solution will be
almost two thousand times faster than
the original pure Python implementation
so let's do it let's make some cash
we're tired of working for the man
we're tired of slaving away in a company
as a corporate software developer so
we've decided we're gonna use our skills
to build an automated training strategy
and make ourselves a lot of money the
data we're going to use is a publicly
available data set of 7,000 plus US
stocks this is pricing data for these
stocks every day from 1962 to 2017 this
data set is just a collection of CSV
files where each CSV file represents the
full pricing history of a single stock
so one of these files for example the
one for Apple AAPL
contains two columns the date and then
close which is the price of that stock
at the close of the market on that date
it's a very simple data set and if you
plotted one of these CSV files you get
what you'd expect a stock chart and
graph and as of all stocks have mostly
increased a lot over the past 20 years
you get this massive jump at the end so
the dataset is very small this data sets
only a gigabyte in size that's not very
big at all so why is this going to take
so long to process
oh it's because we're going to be doing
some very complicated
collisions on that data so our goal is
to build a program that generates a list
of trades to make so every day our
program will take pricing data
historical pricing data from before that
day and then generate a single trade
list which is the buy and sell orders to
sent to the market disclaimer the
strategy were about to do is extremely
basic this would have this worked
actually did work in the 90s and early
noughties this won't work anymore
because everyone is doing algorithmic
trading so you need to be a lot more
complicated than what we're about to do
but the good news is that this strategy
does reflect the high-level structure of
how real trading strategies actually
work so the type of trading strategies
rerun this is the type of structure that
we actually use so this strategy that
we're going to use leverages two
fundamental behaviors about stock prices
the first is that prices revert to the
mean now you can imagine a time series
where a time series particularly ones
like the stock prices are very noisy so
you get this like up-and-down notion but
then is jittering around some kind of
general trend so even if the stock is
generally going up it's going to be
bouncing around that sort of general
upward trend so for example you v
average might be this straight line over
time but the actual real price is
jumping up and down like on either side
of that moving average so in other words
if a price drops below the moving
average we expect it to revert back to
the moving average eventually because of
this whole notion of it reverting to the
mean over a period of time so if we
consider the stocks and returns which is
the change in price not the the absolute
price for example we can calculate that
by taking the price of a stock today
subtracting it from the price yesterday
and if we look at this graph which is
two weeks worth of pricing data or
returns data for Apple this graph
represents the changes in the price of
the Apple stock so you see it drops two
dollars and then increases two dollars
and so on and so forth the orange line
is the moving average of the change so
what you can see is that it's generally
zero this particular one it's slightly
below zero but what this means is that
often you're just kind of bouncing
around a mean because if you go down two
dollars you inevitably end up coming
back two dollars or close to it
because of this moving average being
zero so a mean reversion trading
strategy is
basically you buy instead of stock when
it's returns exceed a certain threshold
away from the moving average so as an
example suppose of $90,000 to trade with
suppose our threshold is $1 so when the
price change is greater than $1 away
from the mean from the moving average
then we decide to buy the stock but we
buy the stock because we expect it will
revert back to the mean which means that
it will go up in price again so we're
buying low and selling high so if we
just always make sure when we buy these
stocks we sell to just exactly one day
regardless of what happens then we do
something like this the next day we sell
and because the prices reverted back to
the mean we've made money repeat this
process every single time we go beyond
the threshold and we eventually get
these sequence of trade pairs so these
buy and sell pairs some of them make
money some of them don't
the key here is that you make more right
trades and wrong ones so you've guessed
that is reverted back to the mean more
than you've incorrectly guessed that and
then you make money so in this case and
there's two weeks you made a 2% return
on investment not bad but the problem is
the price might not actually revert back
to the mean so there's this opposing
notion of momentum where a price might
increase insight increase in increase
and then keep increasing even
accelerating rates so rather than going
up and then going back down it's
actually rallying and it's suddenly
going very very high and if we try it
all very very low and if we try and use
mean reversion we'll lose money because
we buy low thinking is going to increase
again and then it doesn't so we sadly
even lower so we just keep losing and
losing money so we don't want to do this
we want to avoid trading during these
momentum phases so we leverage the
second behavior of stocks which is as
stocks are correlated so as an example
if we plot the returns of Apple the
change in price of Apple and Amazon you
see that these time series are very
similar they're both big tech companies
so they both correlate well very well
with each other when one moves the other
one tends to move similarly Apple is
actually correlated with the whole US
stock market so if you take the top 500
US stocks whenever it moves Apple tends
to move as well
sounds pretty obvious I know but this is
actually a very powerful useful piece of
information that we can use to avoid
trading joint news momentum phases so we
use stock correlations to detect these
phases and only use mean reversion when
we think the stocks are hovering around
the same price and aren't fundamentally
going up or down over long periods of
time so basically what this means is we
take these for all 7,000 stocks that
we're going to trade we're gonna take
the returns of that stock the historical
returns we're going to combine it with
the correlations that that stock has
with all the other stocks all the other
7,000 stocks and then we're gonna merge
this into a time series called the
unexplained stock returns and then we
apply mean reversion to this adjusted
return time series now the oil explained
stock returns represent the movements in
the stock price that we can't explain by
other market movements for example if
Apple decreases in price but other tech
companies don't decrease in price so
there's not this general market downturn
we can't explain the decrease in price
we don't think there's a real reason
that the price is actually fundamentally
decreased so we assume that it's noise
and it's gonna revert back to the mean
and we'll go back up again so since only
Apple has decreased but all of its
correlated stocks haven't decreased we
assume mean reversion buy and then sell
the next day this is the hardest step
very very hard in fact this is by far
where all the magic comes in in terms of
making money the most basic solution you
can do is using PCA and linear
regression to perform this process
called residual ization which generates
that unexplained stock returns time
series for all of these 7000 stocks we
don't have time to go into detail on how
exactly these work here just remember
that we are using this techniques to
generate these unexplained returns and
actually this requires a lot of
calculations so if we actually try and
implement this in a pure Python program
what we want to do is we want to run a
simulation where every weekday just
before the US stock market closes we
calculate the stocks daily returns for
the past year we calculate the
correlation of every single one of those
stocks with every other stocks that's
about 7,000 squared correlations and
then we use the correlations and returns
to do this to get this unexplained stock
returns by inserts I bought buy and sell
orders to make execute the buy and sell
orders and then wait for exactly one day
we keeping this very simple we wait for
just one day and then we get rid of the
stocks that we bought we sell them all
so we get to simulate how much money we
make and we can use the pricing data
that we already have to do this our
range is going to be 99
to 2017 so 2017 is whether this data
ends because we're just going to leave
it at that I'm gonna write the strategy
in pure Python I don't like to go to the
implementation but essentially just it's
pure - it's using various built-in
Python C routines but necessary but it's
not using any kind of numpy or any data
processing library on top of just using
Bill and Python stuff so the result is
we actually make a lot of money to begin
with so from 1990 to 2001 we make this
plot is the cumulative returns so
overall from if we put in say a million
the beginning we're making about 60% of
that million which isn't bad so that's
pretty good but as 2001 onwards heck
because we actually start to lose money
so what's happened here is that over
people in the market at this time have
actually started building way more
sophisticated algorithms than this so
back in the nineties no one was really
doing this type of algorithmic trading
or at least at the same scale that they
do now so it was easy to kind of game
the system and make a lot of money with
very simple algorithms whereas now it's
not as always happened is we're
competing against even smarter
algorithms from 2001 onwards so we're
actually losing money and that sucks you
know that's that's not ideal this stuff
is hard so you're not expected to
actually succeed first time around but
the real kicker here is that if I
actually ran this using that pure Python
program if I ran the full simulation I
would have actually had to wait three
years to get the resource that is how
slow that pure Python implementation was
so I actually ran it on just a small
subset and then just calculated from
there because each days around same
amount computation so this is obviously
a huge problem obviously three years is
ridiculous but even if this simulation
took four days that would still be too
long strategies or any kind of building
any type of model requires massive
amounts of tuning and experimentation
and these simulations need to run fast
hours not years so what went wrong
well three steps to computation be happy
we have this return step that calculates
the stocks daily returns for the past
year correlation which calculates the
correlation between all those returns
and then the decision step which uses
PCA in linear regression to perform that
residual ization process I talked about
earlier now to put it in concrete terms
I calculated by hand the amount of
floating-point operations I would
actually be required and to do the full
simulation
the return step is not that much but
there's correlation of decision steps
are truly huge and this is because a lot
of the music I went squared of n cubed
algorithms and so the total operations
is about 200 million which is a lot so
we break this down we see that the
return step takes half a day and then
the correlation decision steps are
really where it starts to slow down now
I'm going to go into too much detail and
why Python is so slow but the primary
reasons are its dynamically typed which
means every single floating-point
operation you do requires probably a
dozen more operations because it doesn't
know the types in advance it's
interpreted not compiled which means
that the compiler can optimize anything
in advance and it has fragmented memory
access because the lists in - store
headful generous types they can contain
different types in the same list which
means it's actually a list of pointers
so you have loads of memory indirection
and you're kind of like Fort Lee in the
cache basically so how can we do better
and this is when dumb PI comes in so
they an umpire is the fundamental
package for high-performance computing a
PI for number crunching there's a lot of
other libraries as well but none PI
tends to be the one that's used the most
I'm sure again as you're aware and
really the key reason why it ends up
being so much faster than people - is
because it has this multi-dimensional
array object that stores everything in
continuous memory buffers and then it
has heavily optimized C routines to
operate on those buffers on the C level
avoiding any Python code whatsoever so
if we look at this end the array class
this is a class that represents any n
dimensional array it's a fixed size
elements must be the same type which
simplifies on optimizers a lot of things
so to give you an example if we call MP
a range to generate this array of nine
elements well it actually looks like in
memory is this so we have this memory
buffer and then we have a bunch of
metadata fields that actually describe
how a tell numpy how to navigate the
memory buffer to get the data for it
needs so this memory block is just a
block of nine floating 64's the shape
parameter tells you the size of the
array or the size of the data in the
buffer and the stride parameter tells
you how long how how many bytes to move
along the buffer to get to the next
element and actually these shapes and
Strides parameters allow you to do very
interesting things for example just
calling a reshape to change this nine
sized array into a free by free matrix
requires no copies it's actually just
changing the shape and Strides
parameters what's happening is it just
changes shape to three three changes
tries to twenty-four eight to say move
to the next row by moving twenty four by
T's in this flat memory buffer and then
move a bike's eight bytes to get to the
next column in that particular row so
you can do loads of things that you can
slice out particular dimensions you can
you know you can sort of iterate every
two rows or whatever and the key thing
here is when you're doing all these
types of operations these reshaping and
slicing operations create a view they
don't actually copy the data which in
this example doesn't matter but if
you've got an array of you know nine
billion floating-point numbers all this
starts to add up so the performance
benefits all that data is stored
contiguously so there's no memory
overhead you have cache locality because
everything's packed
you know compactly put together there's
no copies for common operations and
again these memory buffers that are
stored basically in the sea level in
numpy there's very fast and umpire
operation so operating on those without
even touching the Python that so it's a
basic benchmark of adding 10 million
numbers if we use a list comprehension
to add to two different ten million
number arrays in pure Python and then in
numpy we create two numpy arrays we can
I have a loop through the food eater
right through the arrays and then just
one by one calculate the resort or we
can just use an umpire's built in
addition operator and we see this is the
timings we get and this is on just the
map book that I have so one second for
Python numpy with the looping takes 3.4
seconds and then the built-in Don PI X
naught point naught 3 so the built-in
operator is 36 times faster now what's
interesting here this isn't surprising
than pi is obviously faster but what's
interesting is that the numpy with the
loop is slower in fact it's almost four
times slower than the pure pipe
implementation and this is because when
you're explicitly looping over numpy
arrays you basically lost all the
benefit of actually using them pi or any
of these libraries in the first place so
if you imagine that this for loop every
single time we were retrieving an
element from one of these numpy arrays
we're going into the sea level we're
going into that memory buffer and then
we're copying out as a Python integer in
the PI foot level so we're actually
doing three copies for every iteration
there and it's written over 10 million
numbers that's 30 million copies plus
you
for all the function call overheads of
calling gas item on the numpy raise
every single time now the real real way
to use numpy in these types of libraries
is to try and push ever all the
computation and all the looping into the
numpy level so here we have C equals a
plus 1 a plus B sorry and that's just
one function call in Python and
everything else is run in the numpy
layer and that means you don't have any
you're removing any potential Python
overhead so the key here is you keep it
in numpy you don't loop through these
arrays and you move the computation to
the native level where possible so when
we use numpy for the trading simulation
just to give you a recap these are the
three steps that were computationally
heavy in the simulation if we focus on
the first step we don't have time to
cover how an umpire's using the second
then the second or third steps this
first step is quite simple all we try to
do is calculate the stocks returns for
the past year now the returns here that
we're using are normalized so we're
using the percentage return this is
today's price minus yesterday's price
over yesterday's price so you get the
percentage change from date from each
day what the price of each stock is so
as an example in for Apple if you wanted
to calculate the returns on the second
of August we simply say 155 minus 1 for
8 which is the price on the previous day
divide it by 1 for 8 and you get a 4.7
so the return is 4.7 it's increased by
4.7 so if you bought it the day before
and then sold it the next day you would
have made 4.7 profit out of it so we
need to calculate this return for all
stocks on all days we could use a nested
for loop for stock in stocks for date in
all the dates that we want to calculate
the returns for but of course as we've
established that's slow lots of copies
and slow operations are being run in
Python code so instead what we're going
to do is use numpy to compute these
returns we're going to pack all the
stock prices for all the dates in one
compact matrix and then we're going to
perform bulk operations on this matrix
so if you imagine this stop price matrix
where one dimension is the stocks and
the other dimension is the price is the
date then what we want to do is take
this matrix of prices and dates Nannes
where you don't have any pricing
information and you want to calculate as
a returns matrix where each cell
represents the change in price
from the previous day so essentially
what this means is to calculate this
cell this red cell on the right returns
matrix we're just taking that same
called the same cell in the same in the
pricing matrix and the previous cell on
the previous date to compute it now
again instead of manually calculating
each cell with a for loop we're going to
use these bulk operations so we take our
prices matrix we shift it by moving all
the prices forward once to get
yesterday's prices and then we look at
our returns formula and instead of
substituting each individual cell into
the formula we just substitute it with
each matrix so we just do pricing matrix
- yesterday pricing matrix divided by
pricing matrix and then all the element
wise operations will happen in the C
level and that will give you back your
returns matrix and the numpy code for
this is incredibly simple you can this
is a really basic example but you can
take the pricing matrix is you can
initialize it as an array of all zeros
the shape is the number of dates in the
simulation by the number of stocks in
the simulation then you populate it
using the CSV files that I showed
earlier you compute yesterday's prices
with the shift prices matrix and then
you just run the returns formula on the
matrices so you see the key here is this
doesn't have a for loop and the previous
thing had a for loop that's really only
kind of what you need to know and by
this not having a for loop it means
you're avoiding any kind of -
inefficiencies and when we do this we
change this from 462 minutes to 8
minutes
so we've actually arguably made the code
even more concise and simple anyway but
also we've just made it tons faster so
it's a 79 times speed-up now we can use
these steps to perform similar
optimizations on the correlation and
decision steps and when we look at that
we take it for three years to 2.8 days
because it's freezing 90 times faster
just by using instead of Pi for for
loops using numpy race the key here is
the reason imply something faster is
that there's no actual memory overhead
there's minimal copying its cache
friendly and again all these operations
are executed in compiled code so by
expressing data in the spec vector
matrix form you open up a whole new
world of optimizations and this is
essentially called vectorization or at
least in Python world this is a Corvette
for ization
so the prep vectorization in python is
the process of rewriting your code to
express all the calculations in array
matrix form so you can utilize all of
these C libraries and this is often easy
to do like an in this example with the
returns matrix it was very easy to just
rewrite it using numpy but it's not
always you might need to completely
redesign your algorithms in order to
vectorize them and it's actually
actually non-trivial to do so and also
not all our algorithms are actually
vectorizable some of them inherently
need to depend on the states on like a
previous loop iteration in which case
you can't back to rise so here we see
this is the times that we currently have
now after applying numpy the decision
step is still really slow so this is
still significantly slower than the
others and this is because there's some
non vectorizable components in this
particular step and this is what number
comes in so the problem we have is an
all algorithms effect arise important we
still have some ore in vectorizable code
that we have an optimizer is running in
pure Python the solution is to compile
non vectorizable Python code to native
machine instructions and we can do that
using number so number basically it just
allows you to annotate Python functions
say compile this as native machine code
and it will do so for you automatically
so if we consider this example let's
just assume that pythons a built-in sum
function doesn't exist for the purposes
of demonstration but suppose what if
there's some an array and you just had a
function to do so you have an array you
have a result value and you're just
iterating through and adding all the
numbers together now if you just import
the JIT decorator from number decorate
the function with JIT no python equals
true telling' number you must compile
this as native machine code and if you
cannot raise an exception we get this
difference so it's 1.7 seconds in Python
and not point naught naught 65 seconds
in number so you get a two years of 70
times speed-up just by adding a jet now
number needs to know the types in the
function in order to know what types to
use in the native compiled machine code
because compiled code the types have to
be static they have to be known in
advance so it uses the types of the
first invocation of the art of the
function in order to determine what the
types will be you can also explicitly
specify them so here you can say well
JIT the function but make sure that the
returned by you isn't in 64 and then the
input array is an array of in 64 s the
key here is that this is not magic it's
cool that we can increase this one
function by terms of seven cases at
times but you're really restricted in
what you can actually do in these
routines so as soon as you put no pipe
in equals true in that decorator it will
raise an exception if it cannot compile
it to machine code and that means
actually you can't you're very limited
in the types of Python features you can
use so you can just import any Python
library and just use it magically you
can't do some of the crazier more things
that you would generally do in like a
dynamically typed language it's really
only intended for optimizing these
compete computing heavy functions so if
you have these small functions that way
you've got really hot loops that really
heavy loops at its rating like a billion
two billion times or something like that
it's really meant for those so it's not
gonna help if I just do act JIT on
everything and expect it to be faster so
when we use this for the trading
simulation we add so we're adding at JIT
no Pythian equals true to all the
functions that do any kind of
computation and just in case we're
explicitly specifying the types because
sometimes not this type numbers type
inference can be a bit iffy we get this
so we're taking from 2.8 days to not 0.5
eight days so now it's taking roughly
about half a day with the speed up from
the original people pipe implementation
is 1900 so you see on the steps that the
returns and correlation step are they
haven't changed they have enough you got
any faster and that's because they were
already or they're already running in
native machine code because we're just
running Python routines so all that's it
was all vectorized code that was running
in numpy whereas this decision step had
some own vectorizable stuff that was
running in pure Python so by adding [ __ ]
there we actually got some benefit and
so you see here we've gone from 2.6 761
sorry to not point three seven so that
the point is in a nutshell when you're
doing this type of heavy computation in
Python
trying use vectorizing on pi code where
possible it will probably be faster than
even using number for example if you
actually just try and express everything
in vector matrix form but often you
can't either because it's very difficult
to do so and you know there's there's
business limitations in terms of
development time or you just can't
because it's inherently a non
vectorizable algorithm you fall back to
number so the final timings is we are
pure pipe implementation
started ridiculous was ridiculously slow
and this is a logarithmic plot by the
way hence why they even seem remotely
close at all and when we vectorized we
got most of the way there
so when we used numpy where possible we
got most of the way there we very very
much sped this up but there was still
lots of code that wasn't optimized and
so we used number to fill in the gaps
where we couldn't vectorize so we've
taken it for three years to fourteen
hours and this is just running on a
single MacBook Pro so yeah that is
pretty much the talk just to summarize -
is great for research but I'll I'll the
box - its slope is increasing demands
for faster real-time data processing
processing large volumes of data or
training complex models and you can't
really use standard Python first because
it's too slow it's bad for research and
it's bad for production but you can
still use Python of course by using the
scientific computing packages the key is
knowing how to use them correctly I've
seen a lot of researchers in alpha and
for example who aren't as familiar with
how an umpire actually works and they'll
use numpy just thinking is going to
speed things up and actually mixing
slower or doesn't help at all so it's
knowing what they're actually doing
under the hood and by doing so it's very
little work to actually use these tools
properly to get the speed ups you want
you keep all your computation in native
code by vectorizing using numpy and then
using number table - my zoom
vectorizable code if that isn't enough
yes you can hamper analyze you could you
try and identify ways to share your data
you split up for it on different
machines on a computer but I kind of
urged people before they actually go too
slow let's try and per analyze actually
trying using these tools like numpy and
number to optimize everything in one
single process first and see if that's
enough really all you're doing when you
kind of paralyze to a cluster
immediately is you're throwing the
problem over the border DevOps
because as soon as you paralyze using a
cluster then you have all the issues
around
distributed system guarantees failover
as all those types of things that you
need to deal with so suddenly actually
you're making the problem way more
complicated when you could have actually
just sped it up by just doing numbers
yet so just using the umpire number
alone can do thousands of times speed-up
so I encourage you to try these types of
tools first and that is a talk thank you
very much
Oh link to the slides here and also if
I'll be through drinks later so if
anyone wants to talk about anything
relate to talk to my Seng - this is just
the surface feel free to talk to me
later I'm happy to answer anything or
just contact me on Twitter or whatever
else thank you any questions
so number so actually so number any of
the normal Python primitives number
supports and they also number has also
built in support for numpy specifically
non pyre raise so if you pass in dump I
raise number actually has specific
optimizations that it can do to numpy so
non prime number work very well together
even stuff like strings it can still be
more efficient but generally it's really
just meant for primitive numerical types
and dense buffers of numerical data and
stuff like numpy that's kind of really
what it's mainly for you can also use
over arbitrary types and even specify
your own more complex structures for
example of structures that have a
mixture of intz and floats and things
like that but generally speaking is it's
numerical data is primarily what it's
useful
sorry so they can ask a question it
depends so yeah I mean that's a bit of a
vague answer so just to repeat the
question the question was wouldn't using
some kind of simple in-memory database
like for example SQL light be faster
than using a operators in dump I so I
guess there's two things there the first
is it really depends you're depending on
the database implementation so yes it
might be faster it might not be faster
it really depends what you're doing if
you're saying we're swimming a bunch of
numbers up in SQLite be faster then say
using numpy I'm actually unsure that's
the case because you have a point over
overhead because you communicate with
the database the database is compiling a
queries having to do something if you're
just having an umpire do numpy dot
something that's probably going to be
faster although I haven't done any
benchmarks so that's just purely a guess
at this point the second thing is
there's value in using stuff like numpy
and number so the second question is
actually the second point a response to
that is more well why wouldn't we just
you see because if python is it's really
slow then why will you just let you see
because that will always be guaranteed
to be the fastest thing the reason why
you want to use to flatten on Pyun um
but it's not just because it's fast but
because it's in line with or how you're
writing the rest of your code it's
Python code and so by doing it like that
you're making it more maintainable more
easier for developers to use and things
like that
so I think the the disadvantages and
using something like an in-memory
database because you're expressing
things in a different way very
fundamentally different way which might
not always be possible so for example in
number with the own vectorizable
operations they would be very difficult
to do in a database query for example so
you're kind of representing the problem
in a completely different way by doing
it with your relational joins and
selects and things like that just for
the purpose of the speed up and so what
you find get with numpy number is that
speed up but you also get the
the fact that it stays true to the
convention of - like it's just Python
code right it's just a sequential Python
code it is easy to understand yeah yet I
agree I think it's a good benchmark in
fact I think I'm gonna test this makes
also the next time I do this talk I'm
gonna have some appendix slides for that
any questions is there a way for a new
bar to actually use type-ins question I
don't know the answer that question I
don't think so the reason why I would
think not at least yet is because those
type hints inherently you can specify
types that aren't number supported types
so number has its own types in its
library like in 64 and all these other
native types whereas the typing of
course can be anything it could be like
mapping just record it or something like
that so all those types of things
wouldn't be you can't you can't guess
the types of those in your compiled
machine code so I would suspect not but
it might be possible it might be some
plug-in that tries to do so thanks very
person tation we're doing thank you and
thus number work with multi processing
ah good question so you you can't yet
not always avoid processing basically so
if you have assuming of course your
problem is compute heavy and you're
trying to distribute so you've got four
CPUs and on your laptop or whatever and
you're using multi processing and you're
setting the process port to for you
could easily just have a number HL
timaeus function in number and how about
one of these different processes that's
totally possible today thank you
question over the back
what operations does number support just
the arithmetic ones or numpy or got so
so arithmetic obviously general logic
stuff anything numpy related it tends to
have out-of-the-box support for it
supports operating on arbitrary strokes
so if you imagine some kind of composite
type where like a person we have int age
and flow average score or something like
that I don't know but you have some kind
of composite type it supports those
types of things that other blocks yeah
basically usually it's anything that's
IO bound or anything that uses stuff
like generators or function callbacks
and things like that ten number tends to
fall down on because of you have this
notion because all those are executed in
Python using dynamic taking advantage of
the dynamically type nature of the
language whereas number can't do that so
really any area of arithmetic operation
a logical operation and any operations
on plain old data structures you know
just basic densely packed data
structures it works fine with but
anything else you kind of lose some of
the benefits one thing I didn't mention
as well is that number doesn't it's not
that I mentioned that it's super super
strict and what you can do so number
actually has a different modes of
compilation so the know Python equals
true means it must compile to native
machine code so everything needs to be
very basic you can only do very
restricted things in it but if you don't
specify that that actually number has
this notion of if you just cheated all
the functions in your library the things
that it couldn't optimize then it will
just work optimize it so it will just
leave it so often what you can't do is
you can just see if you actually
everything in your in your code just to
see our curiosity if actually everything
in your code with no Python equals false
which means that it will just won't
error if it can't compile it it will
just leave it be the regular Python
function then you can see if you get any
speed-up whatsoever so it's kind of a
mix of both so what this means is you
can often have
you can just naively jit things and then
you can kind of opt you can benchmark
after that and profile and see which
things are optimized them work and see
what things you might need to simplify
in order to get there - equals true Oh
question here no I just you have a
question is there a big difference is
there any difference between using
tombow and site on good question so we
actually siphon as well in in alpha so
the difference really with siphon and
number is that so for those who don't
know siphon is essentially almost like a
pre compilation step for Python code so
it's kind of like an enhanced enhanced -
where there's extra syntax for
specifying statically typed things and
defining things in such a way that it's
compiled able to native code so the idea
is you write Python code and most of it
is just kind of regular - but you
specify you have these special keywords
where you can say you know define this
function with or defined this variable
with this type and things like that and
then just run siphon to compile all that
Python source code as native machine
instructions so not really know so you
won't really get any speed up the early
post potential reason to really use
number over syphon so one issue we know
we've just found with siphon is it's
kind of infectious so you know if you
have some code resize and it means that
when you're deploying your code you
always need to make sure siphon runs so
you've now added some complexity to your
build step and you're also just not
using regular - so that means any person
who comes onboard the project suddenly
they're having to know all these
different CP deaths and all these
different kind of sizing keywords
whereas number is a lot less invasive
rather than just save run siphon on a
bunch of pyx files I think that's the
right extension on these special siphon
code bases it's actually just regular -
and you can just specify specific
functions in one module which is all
normal pipe or all regular pipe and
apart from these two and it will just
work out the box so I think it's from a
performance perspective siphon would
probably arguably be even better because
it's for
you to do everything in native machine
code essentially but for the for the
routines that it counts it's often not
worth changing your whole module or
you're a large part of your code base to
use this this basis domain-specific
version of Python and just kind of
isolating it to one or two functions
depends which I I've got to figure out -
that we use that we like it thank you
some last one question okay well thank
you very much thank you
[Applause]